la première ministre mardi dernier un
drame s'est produit avec la mort du
jeune Naël drame pour lequel c'est
encore le temps du deuil c'est aussi le
temps de la justice qui doit suivre son
cours dans le respect des principes de
l'État de droit
depuis des quartiers entiers dans nos
métropoles comme dans nos territoires se
sont enflammés plus de 5000 véhicules
incendiés 1000 bâtiment brûlés dégradé
ou pillés des centaines de mairies
services publics au commissariat attaqué
ces exactions doivent être condamnées à
toutes force parce qu'elle détruisent
des biens communs elle détruisent des
familles entières et des experts de
nombreux acteurs qui sont tous les jours
sur le terrain l'État a répondu
rapidement et vigoureusement tant par le
nombre des forces de l'ordre mobilisées
que par les actions la justice très
rapidement mis en oeuvre je veux
d'ailleurs saluer ici le courage et le
sang froid des policiers des gendarmes
celui des pompiers bien sûr
mais je veux aussi saluer les mers
serviteur de la République qui ont été
au front jour et nuit depuis mardi ils
sont au centre de toute action ils sont
victimes souvent d'agression et même
désormais ce sont leurs familles qui
sont en première ligne c'est
inacceptable
sans eux notre République n'est rien ou
bien peu de choses et je sais qu'ils ont
jamais l'esprit libre ils sont ils ont à
leur côté tous les bénévoles de leur
conseil municipaux le corps enseignant
et le monde associatif au long de mon
groupe démocrates modernes et
indépendants je veux partir mon rendre
hommage aujourd'hui au maire et vous
demandez madame la Première ministre de
leur rapporter tout le soutien dans le
gouvernement est capable il faut
d'urgence leur donner les moyens de
reconstruire les médiathèques les écoles
les antennes de police tous ces lieux
qui font le cœur de notre territoire et
qui donne le sens aux mots communiquer
communauté
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Jean-Paul Mattei les épisodes
de violence de ces derniers jours
connaissent aujourd'hui une décrue
importante mais je n'oublie pas les
dégâts causés ce sont des mairies des
écoles des commissariats des brigades de
gendarmerie des postes de police
municipales et des bâtiments publics
vandalisés et parfois incendié ce sont
des commerces des bureaux de tabac
saccagés et pillés ce sont des voitures
brûlées c'est inacceptable et je vous
dis que nous sommes aux côtés de toutes
les victimes de violences de dégradation
ou de pillages et je l'affirme devant
vous nous veillerons à ce que les
collectivités territoriales souhaitent
accompagner et puisse rapidement
remettre en état les équipements
détériorés les procédures seront
allégées et les délais réduits au
maximum et l'État viendra en soutien
lorsque c'est nécessaire c'est
précisément en ce moment même le
président de la République échange sur
ces questions avec des mers et nous
apporterons toutes les réponses à ces
mères pour qu'ils puissent au plus vite
remettre en service leurs équipements
publics et nous serons également aux
côtés des habitants des commerçants des
artisans les commerçants touchés
pourront notamment bénéficier de reports
de charge fiscales et sociales les plus
touchés pourront même bénéficier d'une
annulation de ses charges et bien sûr
nous demandons la mobilisation des
assureurs dont c'est d'abord la
responsabilité le ministre de l'Économie
Bruno Le Maire les a rencontrés samedi
dernier et hier encore les assureurs se
mobilisent ils se sont engagés à tout
faire pour faciliter la vie des victimes
de violence en prolongeant les délais de
déclaration de sinistre en accélérant
leur indemnisation et en réduisant les
franchises au cas par cas voyez monsieur
le Président Mattei nous voulons
reconstruire vite et nous serons aux
côtés des élus des commerçants des
artisans et de toutes les victimes de
violences je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la première ministre
[Applaudissements]